maybe just been looking at pre-built
models or models that have been imported
but it's also interesting to create your
models and a good way to do this is
using the graphical modeling interface
of assistants but sometimes you want to
do it programmatically using the ball
from language because there's a lot of
you know scripting that you can make use
of and evolve from language and power is
you when you're building these models so
if you want to build like a large array
with different models with variations of
each other then you can use the
scripting functionality in the Wolfram
language to build these and I'll show
you just how you can do that and let's
load in a representation of a low-pass
filter since we've been talking about
these electrical models so it's just a
electrical model which describes the
filtering where you reset the voltage
and it will have some capacitors and
opie amplifiers that will in the end
filter voltage spikes and so on so it
will smoothen out the voltage in this
particular circuit and we can simulate
the model and see how it behaves and
previously we have changed use this
Association to change initial values for
example the balls in the previous
previous section or the parameter values
you can also change inputs if you have
undefined inputs like this so this is an
input to the model then you can say you
see the name higher here di you can say
that it goes towards a func a volt from
language functions this could be
anything that takes one argument time
and then spits out a 1:1 value so it
could be an and that anonymous function
like this it could be sign a the time
data model time series model or anything
like that so here's
here we'll just have a unit step and we
will plot the input and the output and
with the unit step is a particularly
good way to see how our filter filters a
signal so we have the input which is
quite sharp and then we have an output
which is filtered which is over here and
where the voltage has been filtered and
the first thing if we want to create a
model one easy way to create a model is
to configure a new model from a previous
one and to do this just called an aim
you just take one of these system models
you give bracket take a bracket and then
you put an association of what you want
to change in the models so this is the
same you know as we do with sister model
simulate but a bit more permanent where
we actually write this we create an EU
model which has new parameter values or
initial positions and so on so now we
got got a a model design here called new
low pass which is a variation of the old
low pass filter here and show that they
are indeed two two new we can simulate
both of them and and plot them together
so you can actually plot models that are
different models using the system model
plot command it doesn't have to be you
know different parametric simulations it
can be different models as long as they
have the same both have the same
variable that you want to plot so in
this case the vo and when we set these
parameter values in new model it looks
like the filtering was will I guess you
say we lower the filtering because now
it's looking a bit it's not filtering it
as
me heavily we can ask for a proper day
from this new monologue we created we'll
ask for the model name and to show and
I'm doing this to show you that and one
if you create a model like this if you
just create a new variation of a model
it's still on its unnamed we haven't
given it a name yet so Italy its living
on quite you know hidden in in the
engine if we want to from we can still
find it in system oddly if we if we ask
for it though but it's quite hidden
among awning models but if we want to
promote this to something you know that
we want to reuse later we give it we can
give it a model name so this will call
call the model new low-pass and will
suddenly have a model here in system
model ah I'll show you
that's called new low-pass so we just
saved the model name and but it hasn't
been saved either this new model that we
did but we can do that with the export
command so just export the place you
want to save it and model as you want
save and suddenly you have you have
location where it's saved right another
way you can create models is to use
create data system model and that is a
command that takes a time series or
other time function in the vault or
language for example here we have a
random function and in the Wolfram
language random time series based on an
autoregressive process and we can create
a data model based on this and the data
model is just
you know a set set of different time
intervals with outfit from that from
this component that we just created this
model that we just created that can be
connected to other other parts of the
system but this can be simulated just
like any model so we will call system
model plot will ask for this output and
it can be it can be it's an array
actually still it can have multiple
values we'll specify that we want the
first value which is in this case is
just the one that we put in
now this isn't particularly interesting
on its own but what's interesting is
that we can use this with a function
that's called connect system model
components and what this will do is it
works like the graphical user interface
in suits the modeler where you can
connect different components together
and create a completely new model but
using using scripting instead of
graphical graphical modeling so we will
say we'll create a component in this
model called data model and it will
refer to this this is the model up here
that we created the data model and we'll
call a critic component called low pass
which refers to the low pass filter that
we created previously oh not a new low
passage not actually the one we created
and then we'll just give a list of the
different connections that we have in
the model and here we have a model that
has been created from the Wolfram
language and it looks like yes here we
have it programmatically created
simulated just like any other model
[Music]
[Music]
and we can see how this low-pass filter
filters out the you output signal coming
from the the data model that we created
and this of course can be further opened
up and edited in system mode plus this
they what we just created it lives here
in system modeler and we can further you
know modify it we can add new
connections